Hi,
also everyone stopped DM and meet the stupid meme where everyone says my hands
are tied now. And it's got a girl with tide on her hands.
That is simply not funny to me ever. Okay.
So, um, there's a bunch of right now. That's just not funny.
Online. The Chad and Brad thing,
say, yah, I'll do a beauty queen wave on that. Bye-bye dude,
let me drive by at five miles an hour.
I'm in a parade waving at that Brad and Chad thing. It's gone, dude,
beautiful to with a glove to my elbow. Bye bye.
I don't want to there's that, um,
that they do that all of a sudden catches on like wildfire.
That is immediately not funny as it is funny. Boom, boom. That's it. Stop.
Stop with the with the jump on.
You know, um, the Brad and Chad thing,
it's just so lame. They see white guys and they're just like,
all right, Brad and Chad, I saw a thing on Barstool sports on the Instagram,
um, wherever where they did the work,
where the guys were in a boat and these guys and these five white guys were
doing like silly dancing to these girls and the girls.
There were so many girls in the boat and there was a guy that was all right,
Brad and Chad. Woo,
like making fun of the guys on the boat with
all the girls, man. Hey dude,
you're the dork doing the unoriginal joke from a boat
away.
Wishing you were on that boat with all the girls
seems like Brad and Chad's winning. that dude.
I'd rather be the Brad and Chad than the guy calling the guy, Brad and Chad.
It's so lame, dude. People just jump on this.
I got a white glove down to my elbow and I'm in
the back of a 1960s convertible.
And I'm doing a beauty wave dude.
I'm a beauty queen. I'm the Rose bowl queen on you, man.
I, I don't like when people just all of a sudden jumped to the thing. Nope, bye.
See ya. You know what else? That white claw. Yay. See ya. I don't give a.
It was funny for three minutes. And now everyone's like, what club?
That's the drink? The
dude. All right.
It's the new Zima or whatever people jumping on board with this club, soda,
man. It's crazy how companies can push that. And then it's just so on.
I've been driving, drinking club soda for nine years.
My babies. Not that I like it at first. No. Why?
Because it tastes like absolutely nothing with bubbles. Yeah, it does.
And why did I start drinking it? Because I stopped drinking diet Coke.
And why did I stop drinking diet Coke? Because I was drinking too much of it.
Yes. Was it ever good? No. Cause diet soda. It sucks. Donkey balls.
And I started drinking it because I didn't want to be fat though. Is that right?
Yes. And why? Because I was drinking five Cokes a day. Yes. Because Coke,
non diet is good. Yeah. But what happened?
Why did I stop drinking Coke? Because I didn't want to get fat and cancer. No,
because one time I lifted up my shirt as a joke from a mom and she said,
Christie gained weight. And I said, no, I didn't. And she said, yeah,
I have a scale. Go look at it. And I jumped on it and I was 20 pounds heavier.
Yeah. And that almost faint. Yeah.
And then I stopped drinking Coke then. Yeah.
And then I started drinking diet Coke,
drank white club by mistake. Thought it was clubs, soda.
There's so many clubs that is out there. I don't drink, dude.
You guys know that I don't drink. I didn't never drank.
And I drank about three or four sips of white claw. And I was like, man,
this is weird drink, dude. I don't drink alcohol. And I was just like,
this is a weird drink. And I kept drinking it. And I was like,
does this have alcohol in it? And I looked and it does.
Who's the guy drinking alcohol. Who's the guy.
Who's the guy drinking white Clyde. Even know it.
The guy drinking.
Man, Backstreet boys made some hits. Huh? Oh whatever.
It's the same one fire came through with the in sync.
I should know, you know, some ultimate friends with the Backstreet boys, dude.
I could call up AGA right now, dude.
Literally I won't because he's got his own life, but I could call Nick Carter.
Now dude, Nick Carter invited me to run reshow show and I said, yeah, I'll come.
Just text me. And he didn't, but we have each other's number.
He was going to play a small get together.
I like the London hotel and I was going to go if he texted me and he didn't and
it's fine because I, you know, kind of that meant that I had plans.
And then I had to couldn't back out of it.
So I didn't text him because it was on him and it's fine, dude,
but we're buds and that's Hollywood, man. That's straight up Hollywood.
That's how we do it in Hollywood. For real. Yeah. Yeah. I'll call you. Oh great.
And you know, immediately that person's not going to call.
Todd's gotta be though, there's too many plans. You know,
if you go to the mid, maybe you go in the middle. If you go to East,
if you go to like, they start making plans and you, those,
once you're not around water, you stick to the script, you know,
say like Denver, Denver probably they're so high,
but like Utah, Oh bro. They got, they got an itinerary.
You go there and they're like, these are the plans. And like,
Oh check the ones you want. And they're like, we're holding you to it. If not,
then, you know, I don't really know what I'm saying,
bro. What is this? That's gross that that's there.
There's a little shot. Glass of milk here. Cool. Yes.
That's been there and been curdling. Yes dude.
Yes, dude.
It's been there in curling for weeks. Yes dude.
All right. It was today, but whatever dude it's I bet.
But we left here for a long time before. Okay. Um,
yeah. So, uh, what was I saying? So people are jumping on that soda water thing.
I've been drinking it for nine years, which isn't long enough, by the way.
I like to, you know, the people who are like, I liked the band before you did,
I'm trying to do that with, with club soda,
but I can't do it because it's only been nine years. You get my, my, my dad,
bro, my dad's been drinking cry.
I had it in his bottle, not LaCroix, but like club, soda,
my dad would drink club soda. And as a kid, I'd be like, why do you drink that,
that doesn't tie. Why did drink that? It doesn't,
it doesn't taste like anything. And he's like, well, I, you know,
I like it because I don't like soda and I'd be like,
why didn't you just strike Robert then? And he'll be like, well,
because I like the bubbles. And I say, yeah, we have a widow,
yo widow.
Um, so
I don't know what else to say, man,